this next guest right here on the rich
eisen show was a newsmaker to say the
least
because he and john lynch and friend of
the program jed york
got together and decided to trade up to
the third overall pick
in the draft and then that was the
biggest mystery going into the draft
solved
on thursday night with the selection of
trey lance kyle shanahan here on the
rich eisen show head coach of the 49ers
how are you coach
doing good rush how you doing man i'm
better for talking to you man
you were you were your your press
conferences were must-see television
are you aware of that over the last
several weeks um i have been made aware
of that i don't know if that's my total
goal so
no i'm going to try to change that no i
know you were not put on the planet to
have must-see television
uh press conferences but you know you
you trade it up you're aggressive and
then you could not have been more honest
with the
with the with the way that you were
assessing everything
uh let's walk into uh when did
trey lance have you did he have you at
hello walk me through the process
of when you decided this is the kid for
us
i think that's i mean obviously everyone
wants to know that and that's
i have a hard time not explaining the
answer exactly and then i realized to
explain that will probably take
me an hour so i end up giving way too
long of answers um someday maybe i'll
write a book on it but like
it's not just a simple the first time
you see him it's a slam dunk yes and
that's what i was trying to explain that
when i looked at him in january the
first time i finished with the tape i
was just
i mean i'd gone through about four games
and um i collected a bunch of stuff and
sent it over to john that night
and i was just so excited and intrigued
by the stuff that you could do with them
and he looked the part in so many ways
as a quarterback and then
looking into the running elements so i
was kind of just enamored with all that
stuff from the get-go
and then when you move out to the spot
we do you got such a long process to do
it the right way
so the way i felt at the beginning back
in january
i'm not going to just sit there and
allow myself to be set in stones i
always joke
my wife i drive my wife crazy but the
way i buy houses um i think i like
something but then i tell her every
single thing that's wrong about it i
tell the real estate agent everybody and
then she's almost in tears thinking i
hate it and then i'm like all right
that's the one i want
how the hell did that happen am i i'm
just checking myself
and so like we loved him from the
beginning but then you got
you know we were trying to make that
trade early february so
and i think we got it done a little over
a month ago but um for about two and a
half months i'm
looking through everything and trying
not to jump to conclusions too fast
but um interviewing every coach
interviewing every scout having guys
come in i'm
trying to i don't want people in our
office to know which way i'm leaning
because you can go semi so many
different directions and they're all
such good candidates
but just to play out the process the way
we did to where
i got to know the kid after watching the
tape and that was kind of the coolest
thing to where
i really started to like trey as a
person as a person to be the quarterback
of your team
just believing in the leader it could be
how much he could soak in how important
it was to him
and i think the best thing for me was if
i would have done the process the
opposite way
that's what i was trying to tell peter
on this weekend
but if i would have done the kid first i
probably would have fell in love with
the guy
and then i would have been like man do i
hope this tape matches
and and it would have and that's kind of
when you know it's the guy i did the
tape first which i felt so good about
but you know he hadn't played a 2020
season that's kind of scary he's at a
smaller school
doesn't have a lot of throws on tape um
he's got 300 and something but that's a
lot less than everyone else
so you think of all those reasons that
could make you nervous um
but the kid made me believe and you go
back to how you felt with what he has
put on tape and then you go with what
you believe in
the person and i guess the accumulation
of those two things by the end it was
a very easy decision so to put your
analogy a little further kyle shanahan
about you uh you know driving your wife
crazy about buying a house
um i i i guess trading up you know to
three overall giving up all those
assets is officially putting your house
for sale and then
then then when did you enter escrow with
trey lance
um you know like what were you really
grinding tape
after that trade uh up
to three oh yeah it really doesn't stop
and that's where you know i've had it
goes to all positions
i've had a receiver a d-lineman whatever
it is that
i'm in love with one night and then i go
watch them a week later and i
can't figure out what i like so much or
sometimes it's the opposite you got to
keep
cross checking yourself sometimes you'll
watch a guy who's not that good and
you'll turn on a guy next and he's so
much better
sometimes your notes and stuff will
inflate that guy a little bit so you
just got to keep going back and forth
in that and but the thing that made us
so confident is
you know we got vacation through january
unfortunately it means you weren't in
the playoffs
so i just went down to a little beach
house where i got all my film and
i just watched quarterbacks for a month
and to feel the way that i did
you know especially about mac and then
about trey
and where we were at and especially with
that what happened with stafford and
deshawn
we knew early hey we got to be
aggressive to make sure we get one
um where is that spot and we looked into
all the others we looked into
the fourth pick we looked into the fifth
pick the third one was that had the most
chance of making a move
i'm a month in advance and i truly
believe if we wanted of
i think someone else is going to
eventually and that price is going to
only go up
and that was a decision that we all had
to make me john
um jed and once we did we really never
looked back
and and i think what changed is the
feeling of when you go through that
stuff
at 12 you see two guys on tape like man
if either of these guys were there
i for sure would take them you know
there's probably other guys too i would
take it three so i think there might be
five
um i mean not at three there that might
be five i would take it 12.
and then we get up to a spot that is
high but now i know we're for sure going
to get one
and before we did that i knew for sure
that we wanted one
and so then when we got there you're
allowed to go through the whole process
of
falling in love with the kids really
getting to know them and not having to
tip your hand off to anyone because
something i don't like to do is i don't
like to call a lot of players and stuff
because
usually when i do um they'll tell their
agent or they'll tell someone or
and then it gets back to people and
people traded right in front of you
um one when you're one pick away you
lose people it's happened to me a number
of times and
i've seen that happen just in my life a
bunch and that's always your biggest
fear so
i'm not gonna tell anybody anything and
once we got to three though it didn't
matter
i could call these guys they could tell
whoever they wanted
and and that's what allowed me to feel
so good about it
you know when you're going off the tape
it's just you know it's only half of it
it allows it allows you to believe in
what they can do and stuff but
until you really get to know that guy
and the whole makeup of a person
um you know quarterback is a different
position and it is so hard
and it's not just about the ability you
have to have a
an unbelievable amount of ability that
isn't just in height weight and speed
and it just it isn't also just an iq
it's in playing a game really fast in a
pocket
um having to decipher through things
being able to change your vision up and
all that stuff
and being able to handle the pressure of
something that no matter how good you
are
there's going to be a lot of times that
everyone tells you how bad you are and
how can you handle that will that make
you better or worse and
that's why i mean look at all the
quarterbacks have been drafted all over
history i mean it's a crap shoot no one
totally knows everyone's got some pretty
good ideas
but it's not you can't just go off the
tape you got to take the whole
accumulation of everything
and that's not just a an easy answer or
a quick thing to do
49ers head coach kyle shanahan here on
the rich eisen show
after the 2021 nfl draft that
essentially began when uh when trey
lance was taken off the board
where does jimmy g reside in all of this
right now as you and i are talking
um i mean jimmy one thing i love about
jimmy is
my relationship with jimmy's never
changed and jimmy is a
really really good person uh who i do
believe in as a guy
um and who's been unbelievable when he's
been healthy first on the field
i mean jimmy's been in the league for a
while but he's really only had one year
where he played the quarterback position
throughout the whole thing
and that year i mean he played at
extremely high level
um so to sit here and just act like we
don't have a guy with jimmy is
is not the case um but being here being
the head coach for four years
and just seeing how hard it's been for
us when he's gone down and we haven't
had him
we knew regardless of what happened we
weren't going to go into this year like
that
for right or for wrong but that was the
decision we decided
and whether it was going to be trading
from one of those guys which was going
to be a bunch
are trading to move up to where you
could get our own guy on a rookie
contract
that was really the decision we were
trying to compare everything to
now i know jimmy's healthy right now i
do believe this situation just
with the way jimmy is and his
personality i do think this will make
jimmy better
i'm having someone to push him having
someone to fire him up a little bit
i mean jimmy's a competitive dude and
jimmy
with i mean any time like a lot of
players would have done he could have
called in and said hey i get it
i want you guys to trade me or move me
or whatever
jimmy hasn't done that at all he wants
to come in he wants to compete
he's been on zooms every day i've talked
to him a bunch and i'm excited to get
both of them in here together here i
think in two weeks when the rookies are
allowed to be here
and so um is there a competition or
or because i know one of the many again
honest moments you had in your press
conferences
over the last month kyle shanahan was
when you were
talking after the trade that if this was
a free agent that you were bringing in
clearly that might
depose the starter right now but you're
bringing in a kid and
you have the benefit of having a very
successful and liked within your locker
room
figure uh is he your starter right now
uh into 2021 yeah i mean jimmy's
definitely our starter right now and
right now there isn't competition
because
um i don't believe the guy would be i
don't believe trey would be in a
position to compete um jimmy is too good
of a player
he's got too good of a grasp of our
offense and he'll start out otas running
like he's done before
and he'll be the starting quarterback
and i just see trey
coming in here trying to learn
everything trying to learn his teammates
and
we'll just see how it goes i'm not going
to sit here and say i'll never play a
rookie quarterback and i'm not going to
sit here and say i will
play him it's that that's kind of up to
him when
when he's ready to compete which that
doesn't mean he tells me that doesn't
mean
i tell him hey we'll all see it and i
think it'll start with me but i'll go to
the coaches i'll go to the players and
um guys know when a guy's ready to
compete with a starter
and you kind of get that vibe and as
soon as as soon as it's like that i will
let them compete but i'm not really
setting a date on it because
i know how hard that'll be so how much
did your dad
uh play a role in you you grinded tape
and
talking and evaluating uh lance you know
word is and i know that there was lots
of word as you heard mac jones was the
initial
uh thought amongst the uh major media
outlets to be your choice
um how much was your dad involved in all
of this
um my dad was involved the same way he
is every off season
um which is i you know i bet every coach
talks to their parents
a little bit yeah give their opinions um
my
my my dad actually his opinion i think
is pretty good so i think i might listen
to it or take it in a little bit more
than most
people um but that's really about it
whether it's a quarterback or anything
it's
without saying in my press conference
the the whole um
that this is a shanahan's decision it's
it's somewhat comical i mean i kind of
laugh at it a little bit but then
i feel bad that that's insulting to
other people in our building because
that isn't the case my dad
i think everyone here loves when my dad
comes he
comes for a few weeks every april does
the same thing in the draft every year
just sits in there with us watches it
rarely talks when people ask them
questions they'll answer
but i love having them around really
cool to
be able to watch tape with your dad
someone who got out of football a little
bit
early i think who still mind works and
still loves to look at it
i mean with the way technology is right
now i mean my dad loves watching all our
practices he watches the individual
stuff that's
i won't get around to some of the more
boring stuff and he'll call me a month
later and be like hey did you see that
drill that
chris eric did and d-lineman play and
i'm like dad why aren't you at the beach
like why the hell are you watching him
d-line individual drill right now
and it's he enjoys it and um i think
it's pretty cool for him pretty cool for
me and
something i'll never stop doing as long
as he wants to do it
well the reason why i knew that you
really liked trey lance is you didn't
choose another quarterback in the fourth
round kyle
so uh you know i saw that
that's so funny with that stuff too
because and that back to that story i
remember
um you know we were taking rg3 kirk was
the guy i had ranked as a hyatt guy
that before we made that trade i thought
we i wanted to take him in the second
round
and before we my dad loved russell
wilson and he planned on taking russell
on the force
um and then when we took uh robert he
told me all along if russell was there
in the fourth he was going to take him
and then russell i don't know if he went
in the third or the fourth but he went
before
so i thought that was gone and then we
were sitting there on the clock
my dad goes i'm gonna take cousins and i
was like dad why the hell are you taking
cousins
we're going we're going this direction
and he's like because you had him
rank's so high we love him as a player
and russell's not there
i was like hey i'm not going to say no
to that go ahead and take them
but um i think they ended up being a
good decision but you don't always get
out of get to come out and explain
exactly why you did it
well uh before i let you go one other
hot uh rumor that was out there if you
wouldn't mind uh addressing
uh is that you know and and and the
difficulty of asking this question is i
don't want it at all to be
viewed as lance isn't your guy in any
way shape or form
but because i loved him when i spoke to
him last tuesday trey lance i was
calling all my niner friends saying i
hope this is who they choose for you
because i
i just thought the world of him and i do
uh is it any truth that you
you called the packers upon hearing
these rumors about aaron rodgers to see
if that could work out potentially
yeah the exact truth is um i don't want
to wake up the next day on friday and
see aaron rodgers
one of the best quarterbacks in this
league traded without doing any due
diligence on it
so i just called matt and asked him if
there's anything to it and matt told me
i'd be wasting my time
if if um we had lynch call and so
lynch did not call anyone the next day
but yes i did reach out to matt the
night before and asked him if
hey man i don't want to wake up the next
day and see that
aaron was traded for something i didn't
even at least look into it
and so that's what i did with matt and
he gave me a very quick answer so
i i didn't even tell john to call goodie
so i think
that was worked out i guess we were
happy to get our guy and hopefully it'll
work out for them
kyle shanahan before i let you go i just
wanted to say i've enjoyed watching you
uh be the hc in san francisco and you
know
uh your press conferences like i said i
really enjoyed and i'm just thrilled
that both of us are alive here on a
monday
uh to be here together um to
to have this conversation because you
know from what i hear you never know
you know what i mean you never know i
was a lot of people were nervous i know
but
that's where that's when you get in
trouble when you speak the truth too
much sometimes you let your true
personality out a little too much
and i kind of did that right there so
i'm trying not to do that again i had to
return so many texts on sunday saying i
was still alive
who texted you give me something it's
got to be kettle right kittle definitely
yeah kittle most of it was all my
high school friends and stuff like that
just messing with me saying
i'm never going to hear the end of this
i probably won't but i've
had to deal with worse so how many times
about to say you know normally i say
after
you know a big moment how many people
did you hear from so how many people did
you hear from on sunday saying i'm alive
today
you know don't have to check in with me
give me a number uh probably about 25.
that's impressive um
yeah from family members friends couple
players couple coaches
um i think everyone's been waiting to
mess with me a lot but on sunday but
i got so much on friday and on saturday
that
most of the people were it was old news
by sunday
coach i know how uh coaches certainly uh
successful ones love to to get back
grinding right after a draft i
appreciate the 15 minutes after such an
important draft for you
um and uh i hope this is a regularity i
i enjoyed chatting with you thank you
for the call
no problem rich enjoy it too talk to you
later thanks thanks kyle shanahan
san francisco 49ers head coach right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here